I learned that Natalie Portman's single
now my younger self goes like this damn
dude Nellie Poorman she's crushed shitty
dude love Natalie Portman and she uh is
getting a divorce which sucks dude I
hate when people break up really hate it
and they're breaking up and I think it's
rumored to be that the husband cheated
and then it's like oh okay well that's
you know you know it sucks and then you
learn he's French and you go like this
well it's not cheating if he's French
you know I mean like French Dudes you
gotta know that's in their blood right
they say they don't even they don't even
count it as cheating because there's
doesn't have a love involved you know
did you [__] another woman
what but what about our vows and that
does not have anything to do with this
that is uh something else but of course
but did you cheat no no why not because
I only love you
but why did you stick your dick in a
woman it was plenty it wasn't just one
but of course but
French juice just do it French French
Dudes
Chi at brunch
you know
like
they can't it's unfair to tell a French
dude yo you know you can't he would they
would literally
shame you on Twitter until you committed
suicide
um but yeah Natalie Portman is single
and the French guy did the French [__]
you know
it's honestly getting mad at a french
guy for cheating is like getting mad at
a a [__] for being short or not being
able to reach the
peasy congratulations
[Music]